(peppy music)
- That scene in "Rush
Hour" where the people
come up to Jackie Chan, they're like
"you been to Rosco's Chicken and Waffles?"
I've never been there.
- I usually like chick to be spicy,
so I don't know how I feel
about waffles with it, ya know?
It just seems wrong.
- I just know of it as
this magical L.A. thing
that is at Rosco's.
- I mean, I'm going to chalk it up to like
having white parents and
being from the midwest.
I see it as like a
right of passage though,
as a black person.
- I'm from Mexico, so it's
not a thing in Mexico.
We have waffles and we
have chicken, of course,
but it's not a thing to mix them both.
(peppy music)
- I just expect magic
to happen in my mouth.
- I expect it to be sweet, I guess,
which is not something I necessarily
want from chicken.
- I need this right now.
- Fancy A. F.
Oh, my God.
- Pretty official, alright.
- Oh my God.
- It looks like Heaven on a plate.
Wonderful things.
- OK, OK
- I feel unequipped to deal with this.
- Taco it man, alright.
Try it.
- Oh my God.
- This is how I choose to eat this.
Hello.
- Whoo
- It's a little chewy.
It's a lot all at once.
- My whole diet is ruined.
- It just makes the chicken
taste like a waffle.
Am I supposed to put hot sauce on it?
- Definitely better with the hot sauce.
- Now that's good with the hot sauce.
I like it with the hot sauce.
- This kind of tastes like
it was meant to be this way.
I think I understand.
- I wouldn't put salsa or this salsa.
Do they sell like lime?
- I've never gone out seeking
chicken and waffles before,
but I damn well, I'm damn sure I've...
(laughter)
I'm so excited, I don't
even know what to say, fuck!
(laughter)
- A woman that was
pregnant wake up some day
and is like "I want
waffles and fried chicken
with maple syrup and some
hot sauce all together."
- I would say it tasted like home,
but it doesn't taste like my home.
It tastes like someone else's home.
- This might be my new lunch at work.
- I got the hype now.
I mean, when you go back
to that "Rush Hour" scene
and you see those people
come up to Jackie Chan,
they're like "Where the Rosco's
Chicken and Waffles at?"
I'd be like phew, right here.
(laughter)
Shit, right down the
street, on the corner.
(laughter)
(peppy music)
(piano music)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yea, uh huh.
(upbeat music)
You don't know the half of it.
(piano music)